(piano noises)
- I've always been inspired
or fascinated by weather.
What does a cloud sound like?
You know, even as a child, I can remember
sitting out on the grass and looking up
at the clouds as they go past.
What kind of sound would
those clouds output
using a piano if they
rolled across the keys?
My name is David Bowen.
I'm a studio artist and educator.
I make kinetic and robotic sculpture.
And often these robotic devices respond
to some sort of natural input.
Cloud Piano is a robotic installation
that plays a piano based
on the movement and density
of the clouds as they move across the sky.
As you can see, it's a device that mounts
to the keyboard of a piano and
there's another component, a camera,
that's mounted outside the building here.
And as clouds go past the camera,
the video is sent in
real time to a computer,
that then scales the data.
What I've done is taken the video feed
from the camera and chopped it into
88 individual pieces,
as if they are the 88
keys on the keyboard.
So as the clouds go past a particular key,
that key is pressed.
And so it's a simple algorithm, I suppose,
that says if you see more white than blue
in this little section of the video,
then press that key.
I guess you could think
of it then as maybe
a collaboration where I set up this
certain situation and
I'm making these choices,
but after that it's kinda up to the other.
These odd sounds that
that the piano is making
continue to build or dissipate
or move and change shape.
Machines, or computers, are
thought to be very orderly
and very precise and
likewise nature is thought
to be very chaotic.
What keeps me interested is I think
there's a lot of systematic ways to
look at these things that we
associate with chaos.
(piano noises)